events to remember those killed 70 years
ago and the veterans who have died since
have a particular poignancy this
anniversary the war began on the 25th of
June 1950 with the surprise attack by
troops across the border that separated
North and South Korea around noon people
started flooding into town carrying kids
on their backs telling us the North had
invaded then artillery shells began
falling downtown some of these veterans
were still at high school at the time
but were quickly recruited into the army
as the South reeled from the attack they
showed us how to shoot a rifle a few
times and then send us up a hill to go
into battle we spend the next three
months in the trenches the war lasted
three years with millions of Chinese
troops supporting the north and a
multinational UN force led by the u.s.
supporting the south to this day there's
been no formal end to the war only an
armistice in spite of attempts to secure
won most recently during improved
inter-korean relations peace is a right
that we Korean citizens deserve to
relish making a peaceful Korean
Peninsula with no chance of yet another
war is a duty bestowed by the people
upon the state estimates vary but as
many as 3 million people are thought to
have died in the Korean War around half
of them civilians
that's a disproportionately heavy toll
that means the war's legacy is still
felt just as keenly 7 decades on in both
Korea's north and south surviving
veterans in the South complain of
insufficient pensions and many feel
abandoned by the country they helped
save it was our sweat and sacrifice that
led to victory and to the remarkable
development of our country his more time
has passed that's become a forgotten war
the appreciation for those who fought
and were injured has faded a lot and
with each year there are fewer to
remember firsthand what happened as
their generation fades
Rob McBride al-jazeera so